calling all cars we got a honey eight
seven a Massachusetts beekeeper is
facing felony assault and battery
charges after she allegedly Unleashed
hell on a group of local police officers
who were serving an eviction notice hell
in the form of bees
Rory Woods was one of several people
protesting the eviction of a local woman
before the police arrived Woods camped
out at the eviction site in an SUV
Towing several beehives when the police
arrived Woods put on a beekeeper suit
and opened the cage a beat allegedly
stung an officer in the face and when
the officer said he was allergic to bees
would allegedly haunted him oh you're
allergic good police said four officers
were stung by the bees and three of
those officers were allergic a
prosecutor charged woods with four
counts of assault and battery with a
dangerous weapon and three counts of
assault with a dangerous weapon and
disorderly conduct these charges would
net Woods 10 to 15 years in prison now
this would be a great law school hypo
bees are wild animals as a big keeper
even responsible for their actions yes
under these circumstances she is so be
careful when you get involved in a sting
operation